Wir wechseln nun auf Englisch, kurze deutsche Introduktion, damit alle wissen, was zu erwarten. Ja, es ist gut, dich hier zu haben. Eigentlich war das zweite Mal im Chaos-Kommunikation-Kongress schon letztes Jahr ein Gespräch, auf deinem Ursprungspfiff, das war eher oder weniger der, einer der Reasons, warum wir zu dir kommen.
Dann bin ich in Kanada, dann in den USA, und dann bin ich in die Juniorei- Dann bin ich in die USA für die Schule, dann bin ich ausgeliefert und wurde Disc Jockey, und dann bin ich in Japan zurückgekommen. Aber ich fand, dass es eine Maschine war, die nur um Engeneure trainiert und nicht Wissenschaftler. Ich habe in der Nachtclub in Chicago angefangen, bevor ich ausgeliefert bin. Nein, die Nachtclub, die ich in Chicago gearbeitet habe, war eine, die Smart Bar war, eine Art Punk-Musikplatz, und mein Hauptplatz war in der Limelight in Chicago.
Was ist auch ein Teil der Musik-Haus-Szene?
Die Haus-Haus war gerade aufgewachsen, sie hatten noch einiges von den Haus-Läden, aber das große Thema in Chicago ist, dass es sehr wenige Touristen gibt. Wir haben manchmal House gespielt, aber auch Monana. Unser Club hat die Fein Jagd Cannibals für das erste Mal gespielt, und sie haben uns in ihrer Rede dankbar gemacht. Aber es war ein guter Club, und viele der Musiker, die nach Chicago kamen, kamen nach dem Club. Ich war ein paar Jahre zurück, und einige der gleichen Bar-Tender waren dort. Es ist eine wirkliche, traditionelle Unterkultur. Ja, es gab viel Kommunikation. Ich weiß nicht, ob ich das richtig nennen kann, aber Einz-Zezendee und Laibach, sie waren eine große Einfluss auf die Chicago-Industrie. Ich war in der Tradition, und ich war sehr interessiert in Musikproduktion. Das ist das, was mich auf der Internet interessiert hat. Ich habe gemerkt, dass die Traditionen so kontrolliert wurden. Man kann sich sehr independent und untergezogen werden, aber am Ende des Tages hat man die Rekord-Kompanien.
Wiedergehalten. Wann war das erste Mal, dass du mit der Internet-
Ich versuche mich zu erinnern, aber mein Vater war Chemist. Ich spielte meist nur Videogames, aber ich begann mit Modem und BBS. Ich erinnere mich an diese Zeiten. Ich habe mich mit vielen Universitäten in Europa verbunden. Essex University war das erste Mod-Game. Viele Hacker waren dort. Wenn ich in der Operator-Kanäle oder im Chat mit dem Operator komme, frage ich, ob ich ein Highschool-Student in Japan bin. Ich habe einen Account auf der Universität London, die eine ARPANET-Konnektion hatte. Ich habe eine ARPANET-Konnektion in Europa mit Janet genutzt. Von dort habe ich mit der ARPANET-Konnektion angefangen. Es ist 1984, also etwas spät als die alten Zeitungen. Es war aber etwas früh für die typische Internet. Aber wir hatten keine Slipp- oder PPP-Nummer. Ich habe noch mein Notebook mit all den Nummern.
Erinnerst du dich an den ersten Moment, als du eigentlich in das Netz kommen konnektiert hast?
Auch vor dem Internet, als ich in The Source war, war ich in einem kleinen amerikanischen Schulhaus in Japan. Ich ging online und sprach mit Professoren in den USA. Ich habe mehr gelernt, als ich in The Source und CompuServe in der Schule war. und ppp-Konnection kam. und ppp-Konnection begonnen habe, habe ich gemerkt, dass alles, was wir in Musik und Television machen, und alles, was wir machen, wird enden. Es wird wechseln.
Die Musik, die wir hier hören, ist ein weiterer Kreativ-Commons-License-Musik-Mix genannt Speed Merchant.
Wir haben die Namen jetzt ein bisschen gejuggelt. Aber es gibt Kreativ-Commons, das ist das Haupt-Parent, und ich bin auf dem Board. Und wir haben eine neue Entity, die wir I-Commons verändern. Und ich bin der Vorsitzende auf dem Board. I-Commons geht um die Übergabe der Gemeinde, um die Message. Kreativ-Commons wird sich auf die legalen License, die License zu verbreiten und zu verbreiten, die License zu verbreiten und zu verbreiten. Und wir haben ein annuales Meeting von all den Kreativ-Commons-Leuten. Und dann gibt es eine Gemeinde von Leuten, die die License benutzen, und wir haben festgestellt, dass die beiden Gemeinden zusammenarbeiten müssen, aber sie sind ziemlich anders.
Was sind die aktuellen Probleme in der Kreativ-Commons-Szene? Erstens, es gibt viele neue Licenses, besonders die Sampling-Licenses und die offizielle Name der 3. Welt, die sich mit den Developing Nations-Licenses befinden. Ich bin in einigen Diskussionen über diese, mit Leuten, die sagen, dass diese Licenses nicht so frei sind, wie sie erwartet wurden, dass die Sampling-License nicht so liberal ist, und private Kopien erlauben und so weiter.
An der wirklich harten Seite, der Free Software Foundation und all diese anderen, die sind großartig, sind ein politisches Bewegungsmöglichen, um den Welt zu verändern. Dann haben wir die Hollywood-Leute auf der anderen Seite. Aber es gibt eine große Population von Leuten, die keine Wahl haben. Was wir mit der Sampling-License gemacht haben, die ich glaube, das Schlüssel ist, dass unser Kostüm, unser Kostüm, die Mehrheit der Musiker ist. Und wir sind beide politisch, und manchmal sind wir vielleicht mehr politisch auf der linken Seite, als es Creative Commons ist. Aber ich, zumindest meine persönliche Meinung über Creative Commons, ist, dass es nicht so politisch sein sollte. Es sollte sein, weil Creative Commons nicht nur die License ist, es hat die Metadata, wir haben eine Behandlung mit Google und Yahoo, um die Suche zu machen, wir haben diese ganze Infrastruktur, um diese Netzwerke der legalen Institutionen zu versuchen. Creative Commons ist nicht so etwas, wie wenn du ein T-Shirt mit Frauen aufgehört hättest. Creative Commons ist etwas, das die Infrastruktur für Content verleugnet. Manchmal müssen wir Entscheidungen machen, die für die freien Kultur-Leute etwas kontroversial sind. Aber ich denke, was sie tun sollten, ist, wenn man nicht mit einer Samplingsliste mitfällt, ist es nicht so, dass man das nicht mag. Manche Leute mögen die Samplingsliste nicht. Man kann es nicht unterstützen. Aber ich denke, als Organisation für Creative Commons wollen wir alle anderen Samplingsliste zwischen diesen beiden Enden beantworten. Ich denke, das war eine interessante Idee. Es wurde nicht von vielen Menschen erhoben. Ich denke, es wird endlich ausfaden. Viele große Unternehmen sind bereit, ihre Content auf Marken zu geben, die Geld nicht machen. Du schreibst ein Buch und du sagst, du möchtest es nicht in Ländern, die Geld haben, aber du möchtest nicht Random House in den USA belegen, ohne mir Geld zu bezahlen. Die Nutzung der Developing Nation war, wenn du auf der Nutzung der Developing Nation bist, kannst du die Content benutzen. Das Problem ist, dass die Creative Commons in den Developing Nations nicht genug gebaut sind und dass nicht genug Menschen waren, die genug dafür geäußert haben. Ich denke, wir sind ein wenig naiv. Ich bin auf der Börse der Open Source Initiative und wir sind ein wenig mehr vorgegangen. Ich denke, dass zu viele Verluste entfugt sind. Ich denke, dass die Verliferation der Verluste schlecht ist. Und um mein Open Source Initiative-Hat zu zeigen, werden wir von diesem Problem kritisiert, aber ich denke, es geht weiter. Denn das Faktor ist, dass Copyright keine kriminelle Regel ist. Du kannst so genau wie du willst in der legalen Texte. Aber das Faktor des Matters ist, dass es nicht schwarz und weiß ist. Und so sagen wir, dass 99 % der Copyright-Dispute die Intent der Künstler sein werden. Nicht die legale Kode so viel. Und so versuchen wir, sie zu sammeln, damit die Künstler nicht so viel Verwirrung haben, ob sie diese oder jene License verwenden.
Du hast die Creative Commons als Toolbox bezeichnet, um zu wählen, was du expressieren willst. Ich denke, es ist wichtig, es so einfach wie möglich zu machen, so einfach wie möglich zu verstehen. Denn bevor die Sampling-License, gab es zumindest diesen gewöhnlichen Denominator, der gesagt hat, wenn es eine von den CC-Licenses ist, sind private Kopien okay. Ich denke, es kann ziemlich kompliziert werden, je mehr Licenses es gibt. Okay, also wir haben über Creative Commons gesprochen, du hast auch die Open Source Initiative erwähnt, die du auch ein Teil davon bist.
Also die Open Source Initiative ist, eigentlich wurde es organisiert, um meistens zu erheben oder ein Standard für Open Source-Lizenz zu setzen. Und recentlich haben sie angefangen, auf zu definieren, ob man Open Standards hat. Und eine der vielen Reasons, warum ich involviert. Aber die Definition ist nicht so klar. Und viele Leute, die Open Source nicht haben, sagen, dass sie Open Source sind. Und es ist auch wichtig, zu diskutieren, was es bedeutet. Und ich denke, dass Open Standards auch sehr wichtig ist, weil ich stark gegen Software-Patenten bin. Und ich denke, dass das ganze Thema der Technologie, die wir in der Welt verbreiten, und die japanischen, wie Sony, sind sehr bemerkenswert für das. Und das ist eine Sache, die ich in Japan und auch regionell gemacht habe. Und dann die andere Sache, was ich vorhin erwähnte, die Verliferation der Reizung. Ich denke, dass wir die Tendenz haben, dass jeder seine eigenen Open Source-License will. Und das könnte in der Icann-Diskussion kommen. Aber es gibt eine sehr wichtige Beziehung und eine Distinktion zwischen Standardisierung und Innovation. Du willst nicht zehn verschiedene Art TCPIP, du willst keine drei Reizen, und du willst keine Millionen Open Source-Licenses. Und besonders wenn du die scharer-igen Licenses machst, in denen du die gleiche License benutzen musst, dann kreiert das Projekt, das nicht zusammenverwenden kann. Und viele der Regierungsagenturen, mit denen ich jetzt arbeite, schauen sich jetzt wirklich auf die Open Source. So jetzt ist es wichtig, es richtig zu definieren.
Eine andere politische Institution, die sich um diese Probleme befindet, ist Icann. Die Registration für Names und Nummern ist noch nicht der Titel. Es geht nicht nur um Names und Nummern.
Diese Gruppe wählt Leute für eine neutralen Position. 8 der 15 Board-Members sind in diesem Prozess gewählt. Names und Nummern. Aber im Kontext der UN-Fraktion-Besuch, über Internet-Gewerke und so weiter, hatten wir viele Probleme, die über den Schaustrahmen der Originalplan waren. Aber ich denke, die Idee ist, es so breit wie möglich zu halten. Und wenn ich ein bisschen darüber reden kann, ich denke, es hat mir ungefähr zwei Jahre gedauert, sich anzutreten. Jeder Image, den ihr wahrscheinlich zuhören könnt, ist das gleiche Image, das ich hatte. Und ich habe viele Politiker getroffen, die sagten, einer der Dinge, die es wirklich getrieben haben, war ein amerikanischer Senator, der sagte, dass die Tage des unvergesslichen Internets vorbei sind, wir geben es den UN. Und dann habe ich mit den UN-Leuten gesprochen, mit den ITU-Leuten gesprochen, und einige von ihnen sind gute Leute, aber generell ist es ein Land, ein Vot, das entdeckt werden kann. Und es ist auch eine Menge von Influenzen durch die Telefonmonopolisten. Und ich kann sehen, dass, obwohl Icann viele Probleme hatte, es immer noch etwas ist, in dem ich teilnehmen kann. Ich kann nicht in die WTO teilnehmen, ich kann nicht in die ITU teilnehmen, ich kann nicht in ein UN-Mitglied und eine Stunde reden.
Wir alle haben eine sehr lange Tradition hier, besonders in den 80ern, gegen all diese Telefonmonopolisten.
Ich denke, dass das Icann-Prozess jedes Jahr verändert ist. Das Board muss antworten. Ich werde jemandem über Icann sprechen. Und alles, was interessant ist, werde ich über die Board sprechen. Und ich werde die Boardliste anstellen. Und jeder diskutiert es sehr ernsthaft. Du musst meine Worte für das nehmen, und du kannst es testen, wenn du mir sprichst. Aber die Inputs sind offen. Die zwei Probleme sind, dass viele der Geek, Icann, sich auf die Icann geben. Also geben sie uns nicht ihre Meinung. Ich nenne sie nur Icann-Otaku. Aber die Leute, die in Icann gehen, das heißt, es wird ein kleiner Grupp von Leuten. Es sind ein paar hundert Leute, aber es ist kein großer Grupp. Und das andere Problem ist, dass Icann, weil jederzeit eine neue Organisation sich auf die Icann-Otaku geben will, wir einen neuen Akronym kreieren, wir eine neue Organisation kreieren, es wird sehr komplex von dem Prozess. PDP bedeutet Prozess-Development-Prozess und so weiter. Aber das Beste, was man tun kann, ist, wenn du in deiner Heimatregion ein Icann-Gesetz hast, dann geht es. In Luxemburg kamen einige meiner Hacker-Friends aus meinem IRC-Channel. Ich gebe ein Blödsinn von den Leuten, die mir die Frage stellen, was da los ist, und dann, wenn sie wieder teilnehmen, braucht es ein wenig Effort, um zu gehen. Und du hast also tausende Leute hier bei CCC. Wenn ein paar hundert Leute an Icann kommen, können sie vieles der Gespräche übernehmen.
Zum Beispiel die Bewegung gegen die Software-Patenten hier in Europa, die wirklich professionell gemacht worden sind, war wirklich erfolgreich, während andere Dinge wie das Kampf gegen Datenreinigung nicht so erfolgreich waren. Es ist wahrscheinlich meistens ein Thema, um die Hacker zu organisieren und auch alle anderen. Ich glaube, du warst der erste, der den 1000-Friends-Markt getroffen hat.
Ja, ich habe die Grenzen getroffen. Also fühle ich mich ein wenig schlecht. Denn Orkut war schon nicht das erste soziale Netzwerk, es gab bereits Freunde und all diese anderen Dinge. Und mein IRC-Channel hat immer ungefähr 100 Leute, und im total etwa 1000 oder so Leute, die durch den Kanal kommen. Also haben wir alle, wenn es nur Einladungen gab, auf den IRC-Channel, alle gesagt, okay, wir gehen Orkut raiden.
Ihr habt auch eure Wiki angeboten und habt eure Gespräche vorbereitet. Wie ist eure Erfahrung mit der Einrichtung dieser Superpublik?
Es wird manchmal ein Überload von Informationen. Ich wähle einfach Leute, in der Ordnung, in denen ich mit ihnen reden muss. Aber was sehr wichtig ist, um diese Methode zu machen, die asynchronistisch ist, wir nennen sie Polychronic, statt Monochronic, ist, dass man eine ganze Tag eine Gespräche haben kann. Ich spreche über Podcasts mit dir, dann finde ich jemand anderes, und die Gespräche geht weiter. Wenn du einen normalen Tag hast, wie meinen normalen japanischen Geschäftsdienst-Tag, in dem ich 15-min. und 30-min. Einige Meetingen haben nichts zu tun, wenn sie passieren. Auch wenn du nur 15 Minuten brauchst, manchmal hast du eine Stunde. Es ist schwierig für Leute, die wirklich an mich kommen müssen. Aber dieser instanzlose, präsenten, business-style-Stil ist sehr effizient, wenn man es gut nutzt. Es braucht ein bisschen Arbeit, weil man lernen muss, wie man nein sagt. Ich bin auch mit World of Warcraft aufgeworfen.
Und jetzt kommt der nächste Message. Ich bin total mit dir, denn die Organisation unserer Events ist fast unmöglich ohne diese Tools. Ein paar Jahre ago haben wir uns total mit Instant-Messagen, Chatten und Wikis in Erinnerung auf die traditionelle Mailing-Liste-Szene gemacht, die nicht wirklich viel helfen. In deiner Keynote-Talk hast du eine Liste von Punkten, um zurück zu kommen. Aber einer davon war die Unterstützung der Einwanderung und der Privilegität der Individuen.
Ich glaube, in meinem Sitz habe ich mehr über den Profiling-Aspekt der Privilegität gesprochen. Aber um ein bisschen an den persönlichen Aspekt der Privilegität zu wechseln, denke ich, dass das Schöne an mir nicht alles über die Information auf Google ist. Es ist alles über die Information, die Leute haben, die ich nicht kenne. Und also für mich, wenn ich meinen Blog schreibe, alles, was ich sagen muss, bin ich auf der ersten Seite des Results. Und das ist nicht die beste Strategie für alle. Aber für mich, wenn ich in irgendeinem Fall öffentlich bin, kann ich auch extrem gehen, weil dann ist es ziemlich klar, was wahr ist und was nicht. Ich denke, dass für andere Menschen, die ich kenne, die in meinem Netzwerk sind, ich kenne viele Menschen, die ich nicht den echten Namen kenne, aber seit sie konsistent zu meinem Leben oder meinem Denken beteiligen, habe ich eine gewisse Menge Vertrauen mit ihrem Sudonym gebaut. Sudonymität ist, glaube ich, eine andere Art, in der, wenn du etwas zu sagen hast, ist es ziemlich stark. Ich denke, das ist eine andere Form der Kommunikation. Ich bekomme auch viele anonyme Tipps. Viele kommen in meinen Blog. Die andere Sache ist, dass, wenn du eine öffentliche Image hast, du ein gewisses Level Vertrauen baut. Aber er hat die Mainstream-Media nicht kontaktiert, aber er sah meinen Blog-Post und hat mit mir getroffen und mir all diese Informationen über die nukleare Probleme erzählt. Dann habe ich mit ihm begonnen, einen guten Reporter zu finden, den er vertrauen könnte. Ich denke, diese Anonymy ist auch interessant, denn wenn du öffentlich bist, kannst du auch ein Gateway zu anonymy oder pseudonymy sein. Aber ich denke, die Hauptsache meiner Rede ist, dass ich nicht wirklich eine hohe Risikomein bin. Ich bin öffentlich genug, dass es ziemlich schwierig sein wird, nicht unmöglich, aber ziemlich schwierig, mich zu töten oder mich zu töten, ohne dass jeder das weiß. Aber ich denke, dass die Menschen... Aber die Menschen, die ich finde, die am meisten vorhanden sind, sind die Blogger in Iran oder die politischen Bewegungen in Zimbabwe, vielleicht auch einige der Chinesen.
Aber es war auf Wikipedia. Es gab ein Gespräch, und die Wikipedia hat jetzt einen Veränderungsweg in der Wiki geplant, damit diejenigen, die nicht in die Wiki sind, keine neuen Artikel machen können. Sie können noch Existenzartikel editieren. Aber es gibt andere Fälle, in denen Menschen denken, dass ein bestimmtes Personal in den Artikeln, die in der Wiki geplant wurden, da sein sollte. Und sie fragen, ob es erholt wird, und wahrscheinlich sogar aus den Logs der Wikipedia. Was denkst du darüber? Wie geht es mit der Idee des Open-Encyclopedia-
Das ist ein interessantes Thema. Aber ich denke, dass das Wissen, dass alles offen ist, die Kosten übernehmen. Ich denke, dass es mehr um die Literatur des Schauspielers geht, als um ein Problem mit dem System. Ich denke, dass die neue Generation smarter wird. Wikipedia ist ein Altersorganismus, manchmal hat es einen schlechten Tag, aber du kannst durch die Logs lesen und deine eigenen Entscheidungen machen. Wikipedia ist eine Gemeinschaft von Leuten und die current-page ist ein bestimmter Zustand. Wir reden über das Internet als beste Erfurt und in den alten Tagen würde die Telefon-Kompanie sagen, best effort isn't good enough, you need 100% and they would charge you so much money for that 1% and Wikipedia is the same way. I think that it's not 100%, but the problem is so neither is Encyclopedia Britannica. And if there's a mistake in Encyclopedia Britannica, you're stuck with it for a long time. And so I think it's really, you know, Wikipedia should not be looked at. The problem is everyone looks at it as if it's a book, it's not a book, it's a community. And so censoring the pages or removing or creating some kind of artificial infrastructure to me sounds a lot like censorship. And my whole thing about censorship is we have free speech now. You don't censor the opponents. You argue with them and you beat them in public. And if you censor them, if you look on blogs and something like that, you can erase everything, but the bloggers, the more you censor, the more they'll talk about it. So I imagine if you took a Wikipedia article down because of some kind of bad comment, it will be all over the blogs. And so there's no way to stop it. The best way is to get your own voice and argue.
I'd like to get back to where we are right now, the Congress. You've been here the second time. What do you think of the event here?
Well, I think it's very unique for me. I think Congress is a good work, because it's a new... It's actually old, but it's a different group of citizens that are enabled with a different set of skills and a different culture that you look at the whole group. It's a new citizenship, I think. I really like the speech that you started with and this theme of trying to push them into some kind of activism, because I think that... Well, to give you an example, I was talking to one of the guys, a diplomat that works at the UN, and he said that the landmine treaty, the personal landmine treaty would not have happened without Internet, because now there's so much communication and coordination of the NGOs that they could never do before because they didn't have the money to coordinate. So before, the bureaucracies and the governments had better coordination because they had more money. But now, the hackers have better coordination because they have better communication technology. And I think that what's really impressive about being able to hack everything from computers to networks to systems and that idea that you can hack is the kind of empowering of individuals, which I think makes me feel very optimistic. And most conferences I go to are kind of mixed between people who are literate or illiterate or turned on or turned off. And so you have to kind of speak with a very lowest common denominator and you have to explain everything. Well, here, when I said open network, everybody got excited. And on the one hand it's kind of bad because it's preaching to the choir, but to me it's like my father saying I can't use a calculator because I have to learn by hand. Here you can shorthand everything and get very quickly to the very important points. And to me that's very exciting and inspiring.
Well, we are pretty openly communicating the Chaos Communication Congress as being a hacker conference. What's your standpoint on the term hacker?
Well, I now have gotten used to the two definitions. So depending on who is saying hacker or who I'm saying it to, it just means two different things. And so for me a hacker is somebody the way that you describe it, but is somebody who is willing to... So my favorite thing is what I learned from Timothy Leary, which is question authority and think for yourself. And then the third thing that you have added to that is question authority, think for yourself and hack. And I think hacking is part of that, but then it includes a lot more action than just thinking.
We just dropped the line in the instant messenger and said, yeah, we want a keynote and the title should be private investigations and everything else you can figure out yourself.
Well, since I had been here last year, and last year I didn't really know what to expect, but after listening to some of the discussions and meeting the people, I realized that really this was a completely different kind of switched on crew. And I really looked at the program and I thought that this opportunity to kind of make a comment at the beginning, that was the most honorable thing that I could imagine. And what happened for me was I had to go back and I wrote, I thought about everything from scratch. So I went through my brain and thought of every single thing that I thought was important in my life. And most of these issues like anonymity and privacy, I never discuss with people because I was getting these arguments with people who don't ever understand what I'm trying to say. So these are kind of taboo topics for me. And what was great about this opportunity you gave me was I got to hit all the topics I never really get to talk about. I mean, you can talk about creative comments and you can talk about blogging. And I get very close to talking about the really hardcore issues. But at this conference I got to hit each one directly on the head.
One of the points you had was voice is more important than votes, which more or less also relates to your emerging democracy thesis, if I understand it right. The public discussion is in the end much more important than any kind of election. I think general trust in election and especially in election results is on an all-time low anyway. What are the channels you see currently and in the near future where this voice can be heard? I mean, we had weblogs, and you are also very actively blogging yourself, and you are involved with Technorati, the blog search engine, and Sixa Part, who is actually doing blogging, hosting and creating the software. Because I have the feeling that this text-based Internet is not addressing everybody.
Yes, I may be misquoting, but I think it was Napoleon who said, I would rather write the country's songs than the country's laws in order to change the country. And I think that what's important to understand is that each human being has a different input source that they use. And actually I think things like culture and music take hearts and minds more than text. And so one of the key things that Lesig is pushing for right now is to try to free up video. Because right now with text you have a lot of fair use in the United States. But video is quite difficult. And right now they're using copyright to prevent free speech. I think things like podcasts, I mean, I think maybe more people will have time to sit in the train in Japan and listen to podcasts than they would have time to sit in front of the computer. They'd rather be playing a game or something or watching TV. I think that each culture has a different one. I think music is a huge one. And one of the things for Creative Commons that I'm very interested in is trying to get music directly from different cultures, because then you can start communications. And to me there's another problem that I call the caring problem, which is it doesn't really matter what you know if you don't care. And usually you don't read what you don't care about. So if you talk to newspapers and magazines and you ask, why don't you cover China more? Or why don't you cover Africa more? And a lot of times Africa in particular, it's because our readers don't care. And so one of the first steps, I think, is to connect people together through culture. And that part is it's connected to voice, because you only listen to people you care about. And trust is also very important. And so, you know, if reggae, for instance, got a lot of people interested in certain cultures that they didn't have before. And so it's all a part of a very big movement, which I think is about independent music. It's about folk music, folk art. It's bottom-up. And I think that the Internet is allowing all of this to happen.
I know, I'm a bit lost now. In your talk you were also relating to what can be done. As far as I understand, you have a very optimistic view on what can be achieved by using these emerging democracy tools. There is an ongoing discussion here at the Congress if we have lost the war or if we just have lost a battle or two and maybe the whole war is still going on and others might argue there is no war at all and we should probably start one. What's your point on this and your optimistic outlook for the future?
Ich bin einer dieser Menschen, die generell optimistisch ist. In meiner Persönlichkeit bin ich auch die harteste Herausforderung, die ich bekomme. In diesem Kontext denke ich, dass wir die Krieg gewinnen. Ich glaube, dass es nicht wirklich so ist, wie man denkt, wenn man all diese Konspiratisten und all diese Menschen treffen will. Sie sind nicht gut koordiniert. Die meisten sind nur normale Menschen, die einen normalen Job machen. Es ist wirklich das System, die Maschine und die Inertie, das die Dinge weiterführt, mehr als die schienende, brillante Linie, die Welt zu planen. Das ist meine Meinung. Aber auf einem taktischen Niveau ist es auch nicht eine gute Idee, um sich um die Konspiratisten zu reden. Einer der größten Risiken für die Demokratie ist nicht, dass du sagen kannst, was du willst, weil du Angst hast. Was wir brauchen, ist, dass alle mitmachen und ihre Gelegenheit sprechen. Und je mehr du sprichst, desto mehr du denkst. Und das Problem ist, dass, wenn alle mitmachen und ihre Konspiratisten-Theorien glauben, sie aufhören werden. Es ist wie die Matrix. Ich will zurückkehren und wieder in die Hand. Und das ist die natürlichste Tendenz der meisten Menschen. Und auch in der Matrix, wenn ich da wäre, kämpfe ich immer noch gegen die Maschinen. Und ich denke, das Problem ist, dass einige der Konspiratisten das so sehen. Und also, für mich ist es sehr kontraproduktiv. Denn das andere, das wirklich interessant ist, ist, wenn du ein System hackst, wenn es nicht sehr witzig ist, wenn du es hackst, funktioniert das Hack nicht. Und das ist das Problem. Wenn ich zum Beispiel das japanische System hacken will, habe ich die Politiker und das Publikum und die Medien auf meinem Seite gegen diese Nationale Idee. Und es gab keine Opposition. Und ich denke, dass das eigentlich mehr gefährlich ist, als jemand mit einer Konspirasie zu haben. Denn wenn du die drei Menschen identifizieren kannst, die du zerstören oder übernehmen musst, oder dich zu verabreiten, ist das ziemlich einfach. Aber wenn du 100.000 Menschen hast, alle in der gleichen Richtung mit keinem Leader, was die meisten Bureaus sind, ist das System sehr schwer zu hacken.
Und wir sollten diesen Podcast hier enden. Ich hoffe, es wird nicht das letzte Mal sein, dass ihr zum Chaos-Kommunikationskongress kommt. Danke wieder und auf Wiedersehen für alle, die hier hinschauen, die uns hier hinschauen und die nächste Podcast sehen.